hi I'm Erik Bosse and Coco was one of my
favorite movies from this year
definitely up there among the
pitch-perfect Pixar elite that make you
feel those emotions that you've never
thought you had and the reason this
movie made you cry all those buckets is
that the team at Pixar packed this movie
with subtle details and meaning all
snuck into the animation with clever
foreshadowing and strong visual
storytelling so I thought it'd be fun to
rewatch this movie and explain all these
details we all need a good cry right
and of course spoiler warning if you
haven't seen Coco come on just go watch
it preferably with a family member or at
least wrinkled photo of one let's get
started with 20 minutes of frozen I'm
just kidding whatever your thoughts were
on that short Pixar pulled it from all
future screenings of Coco so we will not
be talking about it here Coco begins
with the Disney fanfare but you may have
noticed the when you wish upon a star
theme has been covered by a mariachi
band even before the movie starts Coco
is signaling that this will be a new
kind of story bringing us into a culture
that has gone far too unrepresented in
mainstream cinema and the Coco team
nailed this goal so well that the movie
has gone on to be the most profitable
film in Mexican history not too shabby
so the opening shot of the film shows us
someone lighting a candle at an ofrenda
an offering made for the Mexican
celebration dia de Muertos Day of the
Dead the story of Coco is deeply rooted
in the traditions of this holiday dia de
Muertos is the day the living remember
and reconnect with the dead when their
souls walk among the living
it began in Mexico as an ancient Aztec
celebration and later fused with the
Christian All Hallows Eve Halloween it
celebrated with the images of skulls and
skeletons ofrendas two deceased loved
ones with their photos and candles and
tokens of things they loved and the
spreading of a golden flower called the
aztec marigold forming a path for the
dead to follow home now apologies if I'm
explaining to you traditions you already
know or probably know better than I do
I'm just trying to establish how Coco
uses these cultural elements in its
story for example the way Miguel uses
these Papa leis picados to explain the
origin of the Rivera family now these
are perforated paper decorations that
are strung up on mini Mexican holidays
here they form a distinctly Mexican
storybook opening for the film Miguel
introduces us to the Rivera family it's
possible that the name Rivera is
actually a nod to
Jonas Rivera a longtime producer for
Pixar who worked on up and inside out
now the Rivera family assembles shoes
which is the detail with the film's
directors Lee Unkrich
and Adrian Malina picked up over several
research trips to Mexico including
visits with extended families of
artisans we visited big cities and
little towns multi-generational family
businesses and the choice of shoes for
the family product actually has some
deeper meanings that we'll get to in a
bit but first notice how Miguel gives
mama Coco a slice of an orange oranges
have actually been known to improve
memories so this could be a little
foreshadowing of Miguel trying to save
his great-grandmother's memory in the
film's final moments and during the
montage when we go explains his family's
ban on music we get our first of many
Pixar Easter eggs a delivery truck for
Pizza Planet passes the window Pizza
Planet was the restaurant in Toy Story
and one of these delivery trucks shows
up in pretty much every Pixar movie the
creators confirm there's actually a
Mexican branch of pizza planet and
another quick Pixar Easter Egg here
Abuelita as a friend it contains another
tiny Nemo later as Miguel passes through
the town he drums the table covered in a
LaBrie case these are more details that
filmmakers learned on their Mexico trip
celebre Hays are colorful handmade paper
mache wood carvings of fantastical
animals we'll see later how the
animators brought these a labrie hast a
life as spirit animals for the dead but
here if you look closely there are a few
more Pixar Easter eggs on the table our
ellebra Hays for Nemo Marlin and Dory
from the Finding Nemo movies as well as
a small version of Pepita mama Mel this
creature whom we'll meet later next we
meet Dante Miguel's lovable Zolo dog
solos are referred to as a Mexican
hairless breed and yeah they're really
goofy looking and the animators helped
reflect this with Dante's tongue it
sticks out the side and it's animated
using these same technology as what was
used for Hank and finding Dory and Lou
the hoodie from the Pixar short that was
earlier this year and yeah the name
Dante has some theme attica significance
as well Dante could be from Dante
Alighieri the Italian Renaissance poet
who wrote The Divine Comedy and in the
inferno part Dante plays the protagonist
who journeys into Hell so it's actually
an appropriate name for this underworld
companion but later we'll learn where
Miguel actually got the name Dante there
are a few more Pixar Easter eggs during
this opening montage Miguel passes
piñatas for Woody and Buzz Lightyear
from Toy Story and Mike Wazowski from
monster's Inc we also see a little boy
wearing shoes
pattern with number 95 lightning McQueen
from cars and masks tan features a
luchador mask with the design of the
luxo ball from Pixar's very first short
the production design of these opening
scenes - such a good job establishing
Miguel's base world with little details
that will later come to life when he
journeys into the dream world notice how
there is some railroad skeletons with
guitars everywhere a path of marigolds
if you think about it Coco definitely
follows in the footsteps of The Wizard
of Oz which is really just the classic
story for daydreaming kids The Wizard of
Oz open with little Winx foreshadowing
the dream world of Oz with faced world
equivalents of farmhands become the
Scarecrow Tin Man and Cowardly Lion his
Gulch becomes the Wicked Witch of the
West professor Marvel becomes a wizard
and Coco follows a similar path with
some really crazy parallels a lonely
child singing a song dreaming of escape
a toto a yellow brick road a scarecrow
esque guide a Wicked Witch pursuer with
a flying minion a shiny Emerald City
obsessed with the wizard who's later
revealed to be a conman and a return
home with the child realizing he loves
his family and the implication at his
journey might have just been a dream and
Miguel introduces us to this conman
arnesto de la Cruz I like this joke with
him in a TV show as a flying priest
which could be a reference to the 60s TV
show The Flying Nun and in the scene
depicting de la Cruz's death as he
finishes his rendition of remember me
he sings the lyric know that I am with
you the only way that I can be any very
slyly winks Stila Cruz has probably just
being flirty here but yeah this is
totally foreshadowing the reveal of de
la Cruz's trickery in falseness know
that I am with you the only way that I
can be wink meaning I can only be
disingenuous when I am with you oh my
god lock this guy up next we see how
Miguel's Abuelita beats the Mariachi
with her shoe now in Mexican families
this is sometimes referred to as lechuck
la chancla me mean a slipper or sandal
that Mexican mothers take off and smack
their kids with or throw at them I love
how Abuelita wields it as a true weapon
a gun or a knife flipping it around and
return it to her foot holster and is
interesting because for Miguel shoes
represent both the family burden
weighing him down but also a fearsome
sting of authority that his grandmother
represents in his life by the way the
director said that the most difficult
element to animate was abuelita's
neck for a reference Molina asked his
mother-in-law from Mexico City to come
into Pixar where he and Unkrich tried to
make her angry to see how her neck moved
and apparently this is really tough
because the woman was just so sweet and
hard to make angry but eventually they
successfully pissed her off so what you
are seeing here is authentic I will eat
a fury another design element that works
really well in this movie is the
parallelism between the skulls and
guitars now of course Miguel copies de
la Cruz by painting a skull on the
headstock but notice how on the flyer we
see the shape of the guitar body is the
same shape as an upside-down skull this
is just more genius visual storytelling
by Pixar's animators it conveys Miguel's
pursuit of the guitar as one that will
lead him into the land of the dead and
he will have to join his dead family
members to give his passion and music
real meaning and act several moments in
these opening scenes hint at Miguel's
pseudo death he vows to enter the music
competition quote even if it kills me
he stands shakily on a loose tile roof
and he runs along the Marigold path
these same one walked by dead souls and
Miguel's hideout as he watched his
classic musical films echoes the earlier
Pixar film wall-e where wall-e watched
his old musicals and his own hideout
Malina says this scene was actually
based on his own childhood watching old
Disney TV recordings on VHS there's more
interesting foreshadowing here de la
Cruz says his mantra seize the moment
which Miguel interprets as take control
of your life follow your heart but as we
learn later de la Cruz has a more
literal interpretation of this
he literally seized or stole his moment
from Hector
he stole Hector's entire songbook and
Exploited Hector's talent to get famous
so in retrospect I will eat his
heartless crushing of Miguel's guitar
and thus his dreams to become the next
de la Cruz end up being redeemed she's
right to distrust de la Cruz a glory hog
who puts his own ego before all else
next Miguel runs to the cemetery to
steal de la Cruz's guitar & on the sign
we see the name of the town Santa
Cecilia in Roman Catholicism Santa
Cecilia or Saint Cecilia is the patron
saint of musicians now Miguel's stealing
of the guitar cursing him banishing him
to the land of the dead is another
aspect for a Mexican folklore and really
folklore from many cultures that warn
stealing from the dead curses you and I
like how this seen visually explains
this transition to the afterlife by
showing Miguel falling into a literal
open grave by the way notice how the
woman
helping him out of a grave where is a
fancy victorian-era hat now this is a
depiction of LOC Oliveira Katrina a
famous icon of dia de Muertos the image
of a female skeleton wearing a Chapo in
a tenday a fancy European style hat from
the early 20th century now the design of
the Marigold bridge and the land of the
dead is just so visually stunning you
may have seen the filmmakers gush about
the work that went into this in the
video that rolled before the film now
they've also said in interviews that
this look is based on real-world
architecture in Mexico City and
Guanajuato which is known for colorful
houses on hillsides that look like
they're stacked on top of each other
they also worked in Aztec architecture
into the design notice how each of the
bridges lead to these Aztec pyramids
these pyramids are the first checkpoints
on the journey into the Land of the Dead
perhaps representing how Aztec
traditions and skull lichen ography
we're the original base of the ado
mortos
now we get a cameo in this scene by
actor John Ratzenberger who has voiced a
character in pretty much every Pixar
movie here he plays one or two Don SIA
the word for orthodontist to joke about
this characters teeth still being
covered in braces another interesting
world design element notice how all the
technology in the land of the Dead is
old obsolete dead if you will technology
turn dial phones 80s Macintoshes old
walkie talkies and another quick Pixar
Easter Egg this room number on the
customs office is a 113 which has shown
up in nearly everything that's been
animated in the past 20 years
a 113 is the number of a classroom at
Cal arts were several Pixar animator
studied at the end of the movie there's
actually another numeric Easter Egg when
Victor gets approved to return to the
land of the living the screen reads 1-1
3-8 now that could be a reference to th
X 1-1 3-8 George Lucas's first film this
number also shows up in a lot of movies
as nods to Lucas now notice this detail
of Miguel's fading Hannah this is a
design influenced from Back to the
Future which is another film that Coco
seems to be following in the footsteps
of like Marty McFly Miguel is an
aspiring guitarist who journeys to an
antiquated bizarro world where he has to
save his family by reuniting his
patriarch and its matriarch that task
involves an old family photo getting up
on stage and playing a song that reminds
the family members how much they love
each other and saving the life of his
wacky companion who guided him through
this journey and like in Wizard of Oz
balsa features the kid waking up at the
end a subtle implication that this
journey might have been a dream next we
meet Pepita mom
celebre hey creature it has a design
similar to a Camaro with the body and
head of a big cat like a tiger Jaguar
eagle wings and talons on the back legs
and RAM hordes and it looks like an
iguana type tail and this may be obvious
but I really like the storytelling
choice to disguise Miguel with skull
makeup this of course is the same look
people wear for dia de Muertos in the
real world to celebrate the idea of
souls walking among the living and to
deceptively blur those lines here Miguel
is doing exactly that he is a living
soul walking among the dead frightening
them using deception to trick them now
one of the otter scenes of the movie
featured Miguel meeting Frida Kahlo the
famous Mexican artist honestly Coco
wouldn't be a complete celebration of
Mexican culture without Frida her
magical realism and general lifestyle
has arguably done more than any other
person to define Mexican culture and
national identity in the 20th century
and like many artists Frida was
appreciated more after her death so it
makes sense that she would be so active
in this afterlife there's a few cultural
references to free to here including
nods to her still life paintings of
fruit and cacti she also has an allegory
hey of a monkey referencing Frida's pet
monkeys that she actually had and she
loves Dante reference seeing how Frida
actually repopulate solo dogs by
including them in her art next Hector
and Miguel meet she crooned voiced by
edward james olmos his fate shows us
what happens in this world when the dead
souls are forgotten this actually comes
from a real world concept that has been
attributed to a quote by the street
artist Banksy though he's probably
quoting someone else so I can't remember
they say you died twice one time when he
stopped breathing in a second time a bit
later on when somebody says your name
for the last time this scene comes at
the exact midpoint of the film and it's
packed with meaning for Hector first it
shows him what will happen him if he is
forgotten giving real stakes to this
character art but also him singing the
lullaby to cheek her own hints that
Hector is a truly talented musician and
it foreshadows his later lullaby for his
daughter Coco and perhaps the cleverest
visual foreshadowing of this film notice
how Hector pours two drinks drinking one
and leaving another untouched for she
korone
this close up sets up the reveal of
Hector's murder later de la Cruz poured
two drinks with Hector drinking one
while the other was left untouched
because de la Cruz knew it was poison
Pixar you clever Zola we get a few more
pics on our Easter eggs with an
Incredibles poster on the wall of an
alley
an emo musician in the contest wearing
the same black skull t-shirt that Sid
wore in Toy Story I also liked how
before the contest Hector tells Miguel
not to sing remember me de la Cruz's
biggest hit that he's probably annoyed
was bastardized from a personal lullaby
between him and his daughter - this
annoying romanticized pop hit instead he
loves the idea of Miguel performing Poco
Loco which he probably wrote intending
to be a fun crowd-pleaser and it totally
works with the boy and his secret
great-great-grandfather harmonizing
perfectly right moving on to de la
Cruz's party which contains even more
cameo references to Mexican pop culture
in Lyon outside is Santo a famous
luchador wrestler he was also known as
in Mass Colorado de plata masked in
silver for his silver mask his date is
Maria Felix a super famous actress and
singer from the Golden Age of Mexican
cinema later de la Cruz takes a photo
with Mexican actor and comedian Pedro
Infante and singer / actor jorge negrete
these two entertainers were actually the
main influences on the development of de
la Cruz's character and later on when
they were singing with de la Cruz we got
a couple other cameos by Mexican
wrestler and movie actor Cantinflas in
Mexican revolutionary fighter
Emiliano Zapata and many ways Coco as a
film forms a sort of ofrenda to these
figures in the movies closing credits
Pixar included an additional ofrenda to
the deceased loved ones who inspired
them including a picture of Walt Disney
now a few other fun animation details in
this scene the lamp posts outside de la
Cruz's mansion are shaped like musical
treble clefs and his three Halle Berry
hate chihuahuas are modeled on the three
bear cub brothers and brave shout-out to
Kelly for catching that one and if you
listen closely you can actually hear
where Miguel got the name for Dante his
solo dog in one of the de la Cruz films
blamed the background he calls his horse
Dante moving on to Miguel and Hector in
the cave prison and the reveal that
hectored not dela Cruz is the Rivera
family patriarch through this
gut-wrenching flashback to Hector
serenading young Coco with the song
remember me
kind of like the phrase Caesar moment
the lyrics of remember me are another
example of seemingly simple phrases
introduced in the first act that later
contain more profound meaning the song
was contributed to this film by Robert
Lopez and Kristen anderson-lopez they
were the ones who did the music for
frozen and the musical Avenue Q and it
sums up the theme of coke
go as a whole that love never dies so
long as we keep loved ones in our
memories
okay real tears here so let's um jump
ahead to these sunrise concert finale we
get a fun cameo by an animated version
of Michael Giacchino who composed a
score to this film along with other
Pixar movies inside out up and
ratatouille fittingly he plays the
orchestra conductor the song that mamma
Imelda sings on the fly is called Lodge
aronia it's a classic Mexican folk song
and the song comes from The Legend of
Lodge aronia a ghost of a woman who lost
her children who now cries while looking
for them in the river it's really the
truest song to come from and Mel this
heart in this moment she is also the
ghost of a woman who fears she's losing
her Rivera family after her photo was
taken down from the ofrenda and de la
Cruz's demise comes with two really fun
callbacks
Imelda stomps on his shoe and escapes
with the photo implying weak shoes were
his undoing which pays off the melda's
investment in shoemaking and of course
the bell once again falls and crushes
him calling back his corporeal death
now this cyclical punishment is very
similar to how Captain Hook goes down at
the end of the movie hook with the same
giant crocodile from his past collapsing
on him now this final sequence and the
movie is one of the most endearing
things I've ever seen in a film the
filmmakers avoided the general cliche of
saving the world instead opting for an
even more emotionally urgent task of a
young boy desperately trying to save his
great-grandmother's memory and a big
reason this works is it's grounded in
reality music has actually proven to be
a highly effective memory triggering
device for elderly patients with
dementia
maybe you've also solved it a few viral
videos showing this phenomenon in action
so with this sweet simple moment Coco
proves that both Miguel and his music
hating family were both right and both
wrong in different ways Miguel was right
to follow his heart and to love music
but wrong to think that he had to
separate that from his family meanwhile
his Abuelita was right to teach her
grandson about this family and their
traditions and to warn him against
idolizing pop stars but wrong that music
is a toxic danger to his family music it
turns out is the one thing that saves
the family and connects the living Souls
with the past ones they have lost wow
that is a lot of feeling here's a
question for you guys how does Coco
ranked for you among the Pixar films now
for me I don't really have a ranking I
just see Coco is kind of in an
circle along with wall-e and inside out
but I want to know your lists comment
down below with your thoughts or tweet
me directly @amcgb of movie and TV love
star wars Avengers we actually did
another video about the dark truths of
the cars universe but I wouldn't want
you to if you're too young and if you
really want to help us grow as a channel
you can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our donors especially
katrina armstrong thanks for watching
bye